welcome back to new rockstars the falcon
of the winter soldier
is now pivoting into its end game
leaving us wondering
will this series leave us dancing like
zemo or pounding the [ __ ] over out of
our keyboards
like john walker ah why well
uh i'm eric voss this is rogue theory
with me to go rogue today
is an amazing panel including friend of
the show comedian and writer erica wusu
hey everybody hey man also returning the
show from rooster teeth in the no dumb
answers podcast kayla milton
hey what's up thanks for having me again
glad to have you back and co-host of the
film lost the first podcast eddie
villanueva
what is up guys i am stoked to get into
this conversation honestly just
let's just run into this man let's do it
let's uh let's dive head in we're now
looking ahead to the finale of the
falcon the winter soldier
john walker has gone down a very dark
path an immediate threat to our heroes
sam and bucky
sam seems to be echoing the politics of
the flag smashers and as always the
power broker is watching
but here i want to play some bets for
how we think this series is going to
wrap up
and what state it will lead the mcu in
going forward
because it's interesting when you go to
look back at wanda vision that show
ended
in a way that kind of gave more depth to
wanda's character give us more context
to the world but really aside from white
vision all the things that it introduced
you could say could really be recapped
in the first act exposition of any
future film
like did wanda really change given her
status in that post-credits scene
so how essential of viewing do we expect
the falcon winter soldier to be for
future marvel titles
and what do we think like the closing
image and uh closing stakes of this
series are gonna be
i i honestly think this this this series
is going to
so not to sound like a debbie downer but
i feel like
one division really kind of prepped us
for what to expect when it comes to
marvel
tv series so with this one um i want to
hopefully see some progress of the
dynamic between bucky and sam but
obviously no good thing doesn't go
through its own fire and we know that
there's going to be a point to where
they completely come at odds
which maybe as you mentioned uh sam may
essentially
join the side of the flag smashers and
bucky may be on the side of you know
we need to have peace we need to not so
much on john walker's side but
on the opposite end of that uh battle
and i feel like we're gonna see
something of a solidification not only
of their dynamic and their teamwork
which we've seen
several times throughout comic book
history but we'll also get a chance to
see
hopefully what we've all been hoping to
see which is uh
bucky with the shield at the tail end
because let's be honest we haven't seen
any of the scenes from the trailers yet
uh those first few trailers that came
out where bucky or was sam's
throwing the shield and uh so that's
that's my hope yeah
yeah okay so we have one vote for
bucky's gonna wield the shield
what are some other takes do you guys
think it's gonna be another character
like to just end the show with yeah who
do we think is gonna walk away will
anyone walk away with the shield will be
no one or is it gonna be a particular
uh successor i mean i feel like in my
heart of hearts i would like if they
co-parented the shield maybe
this one gets weekends and it's kind of
like a like a two-minute
like uh that that one uh arc where it
was just like man there's a lot of
robin's running around lately but it's
just like multiple captain americas like
it's like uh it's like the difference
between like an east coast like a east
coast west coast uh
situation
[Laughter]
but i feel like i don't know i'm kind of
hoping that the
uh see the series kind of amps up more
towards just getting us
acquainted with the thought of maybe
introducing mutants into the mcu later
on
as opposed to a specific character i was
i was getting little pictures of like
the sons of batman from uh
dark knight returns here we're gonna get
the sons of cap over here
except it's like the bros of cap it's
just it's just his homies all taking
over his home for him
just nodding what do you think of wu su
well i think uh little johnny walker is
literally drunk with power
uh running around with that shield and
he needs to be stopped
so i think in these last two episodes uh
uh falcon and the winter soldier are
really going to put kibash on it and
bring true what we've seen in the
trailers of sam being the one wielding
the shield and becoming
black cat is what i like to call him uh
the new and the future
future uh captain america i think he's
gonna wield the shield
with the falcon wings he's going to fly
over the united states and the world
like looking like a majestic black bald
eagle with the cap shield
and that's going to be amazing and he's
going to put a stop to john walker
and also to the flag smashers even
though we see him becoming more and more
sympathetic to their cause
my biggest thing about about bucky taken
is because this series so far has pushed
so much autonomy
with uh with sam in having him create
his own hero
i don't know if it would be in some
sense of kind of back pedaling for him
to just take on the
a mantle that's already been established
without him fully establishing himself
as the unique hero that's kind of why i
you know kind of went in the direction
of bucky
but i could also see eric you know sam
as well taking
the uh the mantle as well and taking on
that shield yeah that's what i'm kind of
wondering because
the way one division ended i think feige
in the back of his mind is like well
we love these shows we want everyone to
watch these shows but realistically not
everyone's gonna watch these shows some
people are just gonna go
they're gonna skip the show and go movie
to movie and i wonder if he's like okay
well the end goal is sam is gonna have
that shield at the end because that's
who cap handed it to
but like the journey of these six
episodes is sam uh you know trying to
shake off that imposter syndrome or that
feeling of like
it's not mine it's it's steve's and then
it takes
someone like john walker carrying it to
help sam realize that he truly is the
worthy successor of it
yeah or at least like at the minimum
he's like okay it may not be my
it may not be mine but it's definitely
not that guys i feel like
that's yeah yeah yeah you don't truly
realize that you love something it's
like when someone else uh wears your
jersey it's like i should have retired
that jersey why is someone else wearing
that number
god damn it i mean we didn't see john
walker with his number on his uh old
jersey number and those are bringing
back high school nightmares over here
thanks a lot
my whole life is high school nightmares
hey kids when you graduate high school
people still act the same way in the
rest of your life they're just stronger
they have more money
but in other ways it gets a lot better
and we show up on youtube
so yeah yeah that's right but i want to
know we're talking about john walker do
we think this guy's going to live on in
the mcu
as a us agent figure uh is he done
what do you guys think i don't think so
to be honest i mean u.s
u.s agent and u.s patriot really holds a
it's not a very strong
presence in the comic book in the marvel
comic universe however uh it still has a
lot more to trudge through there's a lot
more john walker
as you go through the comics a little
bit more of him coming back from
this particular situation which if they
delve into
i mean that would be a unique thing to
see him come back later down the road
as uh you know u.s patriot who's already
been kind of rehabilitated
in similar fashion like bucky um to a
sense where he has a little bit more
control of himself
uh i'll be it right now um uh wyatt
uh i'm sorry what is his name the guy
russell
white russell is doing an amazing job of
making somebody who everybody can
absolutely hate
and i give kudos to that actor great job
um
i think though that his work as this
role
is not going to go unnoticed and i feel
like he's going to make a comeback
yeah anyone else have thoughts on john
walker like other than he looks like a
character drawn by
uh god who's the guy that makes the
barrel chested character rob lyfield
yeah he just looks fully rubble i filled
it out
and he's uh it's like if rob liefeld has
had a
concepted homeland here that's the vibe
that yeah
i i agree i agree okay so john walker
seems to be on one path
zemo seems on his own path i never
really know where that guy
is at oh so do you think that zemo might
have a future in the mcu after this is
he going back to jail
is he going to be a free man wreaking
havoc in other ways i think he's going
to stay out of jail
uh especially since the dorm elijah are
after his tale
you're hunting him and he's in the
sewers or in back walls or something and
wherever they're at uh and i think he's
gonna continue to be out and about
because
everything he's doing is to his own ends
even though we don't know all the things
that he's doing or what it's all leading
up to
we just know that he's out for himself
and you know bucky getting him out of
jail couldn't have been the
couldn't have been more advantageous to
baron zemo
so i think he's going to continue to be
out and about wreaking havoc in the mcu
he might have some sort of ties to you
know other eastern european countries he
might have
tied to budapest we don't know we might
see a crossover with
him appearing or popping up in the black
widow film
or some lore with that um but yeah baron
zemo is definitely going to keep out
here
keep being out here running amok the
man's a freaking baron i mean he's got
who would have done he's got all this
money showing up in like badass
apartments over here in this part and
he's got a
private jet over here like man
let me be his friend yeah he's uh he's
the only
exactly he's the only a marvel villain
outside of uh tony stark that could show
up in gucci
and yes i do consider tony stark a
villain yeah
hey i mean one thing i really loved
about one division is that kept agatha
harkness active
and alive in that world and i think
they should do the same thing with zemo
i want to see the same thing with john
walker i want all these bad guys in the
same way
now we get a show about loki like how
great is that um
and in the same way that like heroes are
just like around every corner
i want like these [ __ ] to be around
every corner
to just like mess things up you know or
or shift the balance of power at a
moment's notice
yeah i think we should just call it now
that zemo's gonna be the next loki i
mean in terms of
likability him being a villain but still
wanting to see more and more of him
yeah you can't have a villain that
likeable that's not gonna show up at
least two to three more times and then
maybe
the series four years later exactly yeah
i mean if they just create
zemo's dance steps i would buy the i
would buy them
all that money yeah dance videos
um i want to close this topic by just
like i i
you know one division ended with a
couple post-credits scenes and in fact
it's like
last few episodes had their own
post-credits scenes um
for the falcon winter soldier we have to
assume there's going to be at least one
after the final episode
so what do we think is going to be the
big mcu world building
post-credits scene twist that we'll see
um after this series
credits roll there's a lot to choose
from i mean if we're going to kind of
talk about what's you know what's on the
tip of everybody's tongue
you know that final scene and however
they choose to collab with
or do that crossover with a black widow
um
there's the option of possibly even
bringing in old man cap again
even as just a presence not even as
physically
him there kind of like what they did
with uh henry cavill's superman in
shazam
just have him there standing off to the
side whatever and you know it's him
saying
you know good job sam or you know good
job buck or something to that effect
you know and having that presence maybe
even in in like a space helmet or
whatever because he's been on the moon
who knows
old cap on the moon there you go oh baby
but uh bringing it back forward to the
first episode you know i i'd like to see
one of those two things
really solidify its connectivity to the
bigger universe
um and also what we're looking to see as
the year continues
i want to see something happen with
elijah uh isaiah
the original black captain america's
grandson maybe start setting something
that
something up there with the young
avengers and laying that groundwork
um because we know that um hawkeye show
is coming out
and he's training his daughter up to be
potentially a future young avenger
and miss marvel's coming out so i really
think something should happen with
elijah
uh him and his grandfather talking about
you know what captain
sorry sam and bucky's visit meant and
all the things going on with the flag
smashers and the new cap like
that would be dope to see that get
introduced to the mcu in the
post-credits scene for the end of
falcon winter soldier yeah those are
both solid ideas and
coincidentally i fell down a young
avengers rabbit hole the other day
because i needed something to
scratch my young justice itch but
i feel i really hope that uh we get a
teaser
for uh maybe less of like what's going
to be happening
in the cinematic universe and more for
like what they're going to be coming up
with later on
on the disney plus app where they're
just going to be like yeah yeah we
haven't mentioned this we haven't talked
about it but like
here's the thing that's going to shock
and rock the internet for the next 24
hours
for the next 24-hour news cycle i don't
even know like what that would be
but i i'm the way they've been putting
these shows out just has me thirsty for
more like
episodic content so like even if
i i hope it's less of that and not not a
nod to like the loki series but they're
just like oh by the way
this is coming yeah and the run times
for each of these episodes have been
like 40 plus minute episodes
yeah i'm like thank you marvel gods i
don't want another 23-minute episode
that is actually 36 but it's all and
like it's just all end credits
now we get to the portuguese team
[Laughter]
uh agreed i agreed yeah i do love how
long these episodes are and uh
yeah i think a post-credits scene for
sure it's gonna be setting up something
coming next whether it's loki or young
avengers i
love the idea of old cap on the moon
i've been pushing hard for the mandarin
i think
shang chi needs some love we need a
trailer for shang chi and i can imagine
like
they have some scene revealing the
mandarin and then the next monday we get
a shang chi trailer you know
uh i'm so ready for it but a lot of
great thoughts here we'll have to check
back in to see how right we were after
episode six comes out but i am going to
award points to you for now
uh just because uh there are right and
wrong answers i just don't tell you what
they are i just gave you golden sparkle
books
uh in place of that yeah so uh uh kayla
i'm gonna give you a golden sparkle book
for uh you're co-parenting the shield
take
because yes it does not have to be the
property of one person it can be
shared to whoever feels like uh taking
it to preschool that week
we are in the 21st century yeah yes i'm
gonna give you
one just for giving a lot of love to sam
wilson there uh making him
soaring over the country in the world
carrying that shield
because yeah my man sam it is his turn
to get that shield
i believe uh and to really own up to it
because i think cap
chose him for a reason he knows that
that guy's always been on his left
and worthy and bucky can carry the
shield in an alternate timeline in the
multiverse
and then we can focus on that story we
get to it uh asked
and also that black camp needs some
endorsement deals to save the house boat
so
that's right
eddie i'm gonna give you one as well
just because i think
old cap and a fishbowl helmet on the
moon
hanging out with the inhumans is exactly
how the post-credits scene should go
down
so well done all you guys um we're gonna
go into some thoughts on specifically
how this series could tie into black
widow in particular
um but first we want to thank some
people who helped us make it
some stuff we're really excited about
we're actually very excited to announce
that we have a new falcon in the winter
soldier inspired shirt in our latest
obsession collection
over at newrockstarsmerch.com or epic
heromerch.com
we rushed this guy out based on the
first half of the season uh it's a zemo
inspired design it both answers the
question of
who's really pulling the strings here
you can just imagine steven bucky going
like every little thing
i do you know it's it's it's just
awesome uh
so but there's a limited supply you
gotta go quick grab one before we have
to put it back in the dungeon with our
previous shirt designs
and uh also you're gonna want to check
out our anarchy assembled shirt
you can get all these great designs at
new york stores merch.com
now we want to thank some sponsors uh
first our friends at masterclass for
sponsoring this episode thanks guys
masterclass lets you learn from the
world's best minds anytime anywhere and
at your own pace
learn songwriting from alicia keys or
writing from r.l stein
oh my god with over 100 classes from a
range of world-class instructors that
thing that you've always wanted to do is
closer than you think
at new rockstars we've been digging into
some of the filmmaking master classes
they've got classes from
helen mirren ron howard spike lee you
can take a class
uh on screenwriting from aaron sorkin
and figure out how to master that walk
and talk
come with me what what what's next
what's next
uh you know he's got sorkinisms you can
learn all those organisms
master class is accessible on your phone
on the web smart tv
each class is broken out into individual
video lessons usually around 10 minutes
long
members can explore at their own pace
and each class is supported by
downloadable materials like lessons and
recipes
you can find all available classes at
masterclass.com
we highly recommend you check it out get
unlimited access to
every master class and as a rogue theory
viewer you get
15 off an annual membership so go to
masterclass.com
rogue that's masterclass.com rogue for
15
off masterclass we also want to thank
our friends at bluetooth for sponsoring
this episode
so our friends at bluechew have a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
but in chewable form
and at a fraction of the cost poluchu is
an online prescription service so no
doctor's office or pharmacy trips it
ships right to your door in a discreet
package
you sign up at bluechew.com consult with
one of their licensed medical providers
and once you're approved
you receive your prescription within
days their licensed medical providers
work with you to find the right
ingredient and strength
and if you hate swallowing pills good
news blue chew is chewable
like it says in the name so if you could
benefit from
extra confidence when it's time to
perform visit bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
we've got a special deal for our
audience try bluetooth free want to use
our promo code rogue
check checkout just pay the five dollars
in shipping that's bluetooth.com
promo code rogue to receive your first
month for free and we thank bluetooth
for sponsoring this episode
moving on uh we want to talk about the
ways
black widow could tie into the falcon
winter soldier because think about it
with this coming finale of the falcon
winter soldier we're getting some more
closure on how marvel
intended its first disney plus chapters
to play out
like uh originally it was rumored that
we would see some crossover with black
widow
actually by the time you're watching
this maybe episode five or if you're
watching in far into the future episode
six they've already answered all these
questions but for now
from you guys i want to know what kind
of tie-in with black widow
might we see on the falcon in the winter
soldier i feel like every time you have
me on the show
i have at least one out of pocket idea
hear me out hear me out america
2017 a country divided we all
we all know about russia did they
interfere did they not interfere
this isn't thought in america we're
talking about the marvel cinematic
universe
what i'm saying is that maybe
whatever that secret team of badass
women
that that black widow natasha is
was or is a part of they secretly
planted the seeds that led to the
creation of the flag smashers
whoa wow that's a cool idea i love that
because it was a few years ago right it
was before the yeah
it happened before the snap so hey it's
completely possible
she wasn't snapchat and we don't know
what she was we don't know what she was
doing between movies we don't know
what she did before she showed up this
could have been a long con i've also
been listening
uh to a lot of uh this podcast about
this woman
this russian woman who like they were
like no she's a she was literally like a
student the grad student they were like
no no she's a secret russian agent she
was like i am russian i am a student
please leave me alone
i don't know and that just got me
thinking that just got me thinking
all these you know all these russian all
these russian women
you know old classic spy novel style
uh infiltration into uh and
you know our or the intricate workings
of our government maybe that's why
natasha showed up in the first place
maybe that's what she was supposed to be
doing
got caught up in being a hero and now
flag smashers nice i love that idea i
especially like the idea if there's like
a tie with the serum
you know like because we know everyone
kind of had their own version of the
serum that they were trying to make
zemo was hunting them down implying that
there was a lot of them out there
we see these blue vials but then like in
black widow
promo footage she's carrying these red
fluid vials
i wonder if that's a kind of like black
widow agent serum that doesn't give them
like super strength per se
but just makes them uh more rugged more
fit
you know more badass able to be thrown
by uh alien invaders
and not have their bodies just
absolutely be disintegrated yeah
right right exactly exactly i'm sorry
just to the point yeah
hawkeye and what they're just humans
like they don't have
super like allegedly super soldier serum
they don't have uh
an entire billion dollar robot around
their bodies like how are they handling
all these tussles and tumbles they're
just very brave
yeah and that sound something happened
in budapest
hey could buddha pass me the thing i
mean we're already in eastern europe
prague i don't know i've said prague is
eastern europe and some people from
eastern europe are like frog is not
eastern europe
we are central europe and i was like oh
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry okay
but like everything east of prague i
guess is eastern europe but like
prague isn't that far from budapest it's
like you know
an hour train ride i think prague is the
mississippi
river of eastern europe yeah
it's right it's just connected yes
i feel like the the big connecting point
the thing that we're going to see
is ultimately the
person who is behind because i i feel
like yeah there's going to be a little
bit of a
of them kind of preempting something
that maybe wouldn't have been seen until
you've seen the film
of black widow but i feel like the power
broker is going to be that bridge
between
two uh because we know in the trailers
that there's somebody behind
um taskmaster and we know that there's
probably a bigger
uh force of evil behind that so i'm i'm
thinking possibly that transition of
from somebody who's starting there to
where they are now with
uh sam and bucky and you know john
walker and all them
i feel like the power broker is going to
be that one and i feel like we're going
to get some sense of an emergence of uh
honestly i feel like we're going to see
hydra come back to be honest
so i feel like i feel like that's that's
where that guy's coming back in oh
always looking for a way to get that gun
in there
but yeah that's that's where i think
it's going to come down to the power
broker is going to kind of re-usher in a
new season or a new
age of hydra if you will yeah i think
we're going to get more breadcrumbs of
the introduction of mutants uh at the
end of cab and then
black widow and in that interim period
like
i think with in i was about to call the
scarlet witch
in one division uh there was that kind
of
origin scene where they put her in the
room they put the scarlet witch in the
room and then they
used the magic or the energy from the i
guess tesseract
and it brought out this power and we saw
like the the kind of
uh silhouette of the scarlet witch oh
you mean the uh
from the from the mind stone and the
scepter not the tester act right oh yes
yes just saving you from those comments
or like
yeah thank you for that i appreciate my
twitter life
but like even that was a little bit like
is she human is is it all infinity stone
power
like what is it is she the scarlet witch
that agatha harkness mentioned or
told her that she was or is she
something different so i think
that happened there and then we find out
more about the super soldiers and the
serums and how everyone's creating their
different super soldier serums
here in the falcon runner soldier and
then we're going to get some more origin
story
uh about uh black widow so i think each
of these things is kind of laying out
how different the super power humans and
beings are coming about
and we're just going to get more and
more breadcrumbs leading us to the big
mutant reveal maybe in scarlet witch or
maybe in
shang chi or maybe in even or something
like that
yeah i think so i think that's also very
possible especially if it's just in the
form of breadcrumbs so far
right because i i don't think they're
gonna bring in wolverine
uh so soon obviously but like i think in
terms of a cameo a lot of people are
saying well
black widow needed to come out before
falcon winter soldier because there's
going to be some cameo of an actor in
that but obviously disney's like no
didn't
we're doing it we're it's okay but like
just because the character appears in it
uh you know faculty soldier takes place
six years after
anyway or maybe even seven years so like
it could just be a character who appears
in it whether it's taskmaster
or thaddeus ross or someone like that
and we know ross is going to be in black
widow
if ross is the power broker that's been
a big theory that ross could be the
power broker of the show um
that that could be one way they do it
for sure um
i'm just uh i'm one it's a lot of people
were wondering well steven strange is
gonna show up in one division and he
didn't it's like well yeah benedict
cumberbatch it's like he's not a cheap
person to bring into like it's expensive
to get a cumberbatch on set
and you only have so much budget for
these shows so um but if we're talking
about the actors i mean david harper
seems like
he might be he might be willing to do a
favor you know
uh who knows uh i can imagine
red guardian appearing i'm very excited
to see who though
um okay so for the theories here for the
points
i'm gonna give you one point for saying
that the power broker is gonna be the
link
because that seems pretty accurate what
whatever the power broker is i think
we'll link to the other mcu movies
um not sure if it's hydra though um just
because i think we're done with hydra
right or i don't know i could be wrong
or
are we yeah
yeah i feel like hydra is always looming
that's true
still not yeah i'm still not convinced
that every single
uh operation we've seen in every single
single marble thing isn't secretly hydra
and they're just gonna they're gonna cap
us when they're
waiting their time yeah secret empire
one of these days watch yeah
um well we're gonna move on to rogue
questions and we're doing something a
bit different uh because this week the
fourth movie in the hotel transylvania
franchise was announced
four of those movies guys which got us
thinking
about franchises that have quietly
amassed a ton
of film installments despite people like
us maybe not watching all of them
like you know a lot of us know that
there were 23
mcu movies or maybe 10 wizarding world
movies like eight harry potters
plus two uh two of the you know
fantastic beasts series
um now uh but can you do this can you
guess
how many movies there have been in the
following franchises
we're gonna do a little quiz i'm gonna
say the name of the franchise you tell
me
how many movies have been in that
franchise
are you ready let's go yeah i'm ready
all right ice age four i'm gonna say
five let's say three kayla gets a point
five ice age films
not including the scratch short films
but is anyone
counting the scrap short rules i don't
even know the worst
uh all right next category despicable me
slash minions versus six four
five kayla again gets the point there
have been four of those movies
i live not far from universal studios in
hollywood
and that minion is staring at me all the
time
[Laughter]
um all right next category the uh
tyler perry madea series oh my gosh
nine wait wait just the medea movies
like not like
just all tyler perry films even though
she's just the media one titular media
movies or is this tyler perry films that
sometimes
also feature medea because that is also
yeah
yeah she just bought like the family
just crazed she pops up in that i think
yeah oh yeah there's like one where a
woman's like thrown down the stairs and
then media shows up and it's like i
don't know you go to church about it
so we'll limit it to just the media
movies how about that i'm gonna say
okay all right eight i'm gonna say eight
seven
seven okay well with the final answers
no one gets the point it was nine
kayla you were right originally
trust your gut nine of those bad boys
yeah i know
i was like it's not 10 because i feel
like i would have seen an article about
it so it's got to be eight or nine
yeah it got to double digits that would
have been a major deal
um the transformers franchise
six of them five uh seven eddie gets the
point there have been six transformers
movies
i'm not proud of that but you just saw
him in theaters
opening night all right um
uh and then next category the kung fu
panda
four and this doesn't include the
cartoon series does it
no just the major motion pictures i'm
gonna say
four i'm gonna say three oh wusu gets a
point there have been three kung fu
pandas
and then finally this one's gonna be
tough uh final one
uh and i believe it is kayla with three
points eddie with three points awusu
with two
so we can either tie it or somebody's
going to win it all the
conjuring series now the conjuring
includes
movies that might have the name
conjuring in it and spin-offs of
characters that were featured in the
conjuring series
six let me say eight i'm gonna say
five no one gets the point the correct
answer was
seven seven seven of those so that's
including the annabelle series
including the none those are all part of
the country yeah eric you're gonna get
me fired
you always forget about the nun she's
always out there she and that minion are
haunting my dreams
i thought i was doing good i was like
yeah i got the conjurings i got the
i got the annabelles yeah there's a lot
about the nun movie
james one is a very wealthy man
well i guess that makes it a tie between
kayla and eddie as our winners today
congratulations to both of you congrats
to all three of you a lot of great
theories today
well done well done um that is it for
this episode of rogue theory i want to
thank our guests
erica woo kayla milton eddie villanueva
follow all three of them on social media
follow them with their podcasts with
their comedy shows whatever projects
they're working on
support them because they're three very
amazing talented people
who are always making great stuff and
you can support this channel by again
checking out one of our many great merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com
including our new zemo inspired design
you can follow me at ea foss follow new
rockstars subscribe to new york stars
here on youtube and uh next time you see
me you'll be tomorrow morning talking
about episode 5
of the falcon winter soldier or maybe
some other thing if you're watching this
way later
goodbye everybody
[Music]
you